Dragons conquered the seven kingdoms but
to rule them the Targaryens needed a
less temperamental tool when the Great
King mega saw the power of the
alchemists guild he blessed us with his
patronage in those days we accommodate
transmuted metals and other wonders but
the King was most interested in our
mastery of the substance which there is
not of our order dumb wild fire a slight
misnomer to the uninitiated the
substance indeed seems uncontrollable
water will not extinguish it nor plate
of Steel repel it our order alone knows
its secrets in bare stone cells beneath
the guild hall our acolytes prepare the
substance with utmost care and ancient
magic apprentices then remove the jars
to a secure storage overseeing its
purity are the wisdoms such as myself
who are adept in the alchemical
mysteries should an acolyte prove
unworthy and allow the substance to
ignite the ceilings are spell to
collapse and fill the room with send for
once lit only smothering or starvation
will quench the fire many years did the
alchemists guild serve the Targaryen
spadeful II until we were beset on all
sides by the envious the order of
misters shell who dismissed all learning
but their own and the charlatans who
hopped green paint and worse in our
names after the unfortunate prince
aerion Targaryen drunk with wine boasted
that a draught of the substance would
transmute him into a dragon
we lost our royal favor then came the
wise king aerys second of his name I was
merely an acolyte when he restored our
guild to its former glory as had his
great forefathers he appreciated our
secret arts even naming wisdom Rus art
as hand of the king
together they punished his enemies has
been Fitz a true tiger yet during the
War of the user I heard whispers that
King Aerys had engaged our greatest
wisdoms for an ultimate weapon against
his firm but sadly King's Landing must
have fallen before it could be used and
many of our wisdoms disappeared in the
sack of the city victims of ignorance
and envy as ever I'd wager yet our order
persevere like the substance which grows
ever more potent as it ages we perfect
our ancient arts in darkness forgotten
by the world we are masters of the fire
but we live only to serve all we need is
the right spark